a wisecrack disembody Jared again here
to continue our epic philosophy of
Christopher Nolan trilogy and our first
installment Nolan begins we covered his
interpretations of the self in his early
films plus inception what does it mean
to be a self how can we trust ourselves
and our own thoughts today we're asking
if there's so much conflict already
present in the self what are the
implications for a community full of
cells if we can't even handle our own
issues is it possible to avoid conflict
with other people or is violence
inevitable this is the foundational
question surrounding Gotham City in the
Dark Knight trilogy so suit up for some
time with the Batman and we're not
wearing hockey pads welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
Christopher Nolan part 2 and yep there's
spoilers ahead behind the face paint and
pointy eared masks Gotham is
experiencing crisis after crisis that
affect the functioning of its social
body the mob is pumping in drugs the
cops are helping the mob the mob is
hiring clowns and bombs seem to be
getting trendier by the minute Batman
may be the focus but his focus is on the
city he loves in the process of saving
Gotham the films raise questions about
the nature of community how does a
society deal with fear and threats how
does the presence of a hero like Batman
create or threaten stability can
society-wide conflict ever be resolved
or is it inherently a cyclical process
what about escalation escalation we
start carrying semi-automatics day by
automatics we start wearing Kevlar they
buy armor-piercing rounds
and you're wearing a mask jumping off
rooftops to help us understand Nolan's
social philosophy were turning to
perpetually stoned looking
anthropologists Rene Girard Gerard
claims that the concept of mimesis is
both the foundation of all societies and
the foundation of conflict in those
societies Gerard's theory claims that
one of the most basic aspects of our
relationships with other people is
imitation imitation can be as simple as
copying someone else's behavior I see
you buying someone a badass necklace and
I think wow great idea and I decide to
go buy a necklace too everyone's happy
right but this can become a problem
Gerard says that imitation of someone
else's behaviors can and often does lead
to replicating their desires that's
where I don't just want a necklace I
want that necklace the one you happen to
be wearing this is mimetic desire and it
can pretty quickly lead to rivalry where
multiple people share the same desire
and so compete over finite resources
Gerard claims that our human impulse
toward imitation means that eventually
more and more people will want that
necklace and rivalries will grow and
multiply until they're all so profoundly
impactful on the community itself when
one person succeeds in winning the prize
the other people or their tribes or
their surviving family members seek
retaliation against the winner this
vengeance is also a form of imitation
and it basically ensures that rivalries
and violence will continue to grow
according to Gerard this is the
fundamental reason why there is crime
violence and war in the world as Batman
Begins begins this turmoil is already
established obviously because according
to Gerard this cycle goes all the way
back to cavemen but what's important to
note here is that we see individual
examples of mimesis occurring and
motivating characters and most
importantly later on we see Nolan used
mimetic theory to propose a possible
solution to society wide violence so
let's get started
mimesis is most relevant in Batman
Begins as it relates to the individual
especially in the creation of the Batman
identity the original instance of this
mimesis is one man's desire for the
Wayne's wealth which leads to violence
throughout the film Nolan foregrounds
fear and vengeance as powerful
motivators especially in a city as
broken as Gotham we see this again in
Bruce's imitation of his parents killer
Joe Chill in his effort to exact
vengeance versus time away from Gotham
inspires him to move away from the cycle
of vengeance that motivated him to
avenge his parents instead he uses
imitation as a means of stopping
violence his fear of bats leads him to
adopt the identity of a bat but he uses
this imitation as a means to spread the
fear to criminals who now fear a
different kind of bat him the League of
Shadows wants to press the reset button
on conflict by destroying a society
altogether but that's not really how it
works the problem with their method is
that watching people destroy each other
doesn't actually do anything to decrease
violence it inflates it there's nothing
for people to unite around
so whatever survivors are left after the
fire of London or the Black Plague or
the microwaving of Gotham are still
gonna be really pissed off so if the
League of Shadows gets it wrong what
does Batman get right even while no one
presents us with the idea that it is
difficult if not impossible to break
away from violence
Bruce spends the majority of Batman
Begins struggling to overcome both his
fears and his impulse for vengeance
it can't be personal where you're just
vigilant in order to do that Batman has
to transcend the identity of Bruce Wayne
and become something else an image in
the collective consciousness that
represents justice without personal
motivation he has to become a symbol to
be imitated and it's this idea of
symbols Gerard proposes that can break
society out of violence
[Music]
unlike the more individually focused
themes of Batman Begins The Dark Knight
transitions to the social consequences
of the rapid spread of rivalries and
fear after the mobs ass-whooping the
city begins to push back against
organized crime and the phases of this
effort are Harvey Dent new District
Attorney and Gotham's White Knight and
Batman the wait for it dark night while
the bat fights with batarangs and
farmers Lamborghinis dent fights crime
using the law as his weapon
the White Knight and the Dark Knight are
symbiotic ideas they both inspire
imitation while dent inspires the rest
of the city government to aim for a
safer Gotham Batman inspires copycats in
poorly conceived Halloween costumes
still those copycats are a sign that the
idea of Batman inspires hope among the
citizens of Gotham it's also a sign that
those citizens are copying his tactic of
replicating fear or at least trying to
but the mob pushes back as mobs tend to
do and the increasing escalation of
conflict between the Knights and the
criminals leads to Maroni hiring the
Joker to kill Batman part of a danger of
the Joker is that he only has power
because of how afraid the mob is listen
I know why you choose to have the little
group therapy sessions in broad daylight
I know why you're afraid to go out at
night
Batman's strategy for fighting crime has
created a monster one that feeds on the
mimetic reproduction of fear that Batman
relies on so how can you break a cycle
that has adapted to your methods of
opposing gerar tells us that when
violence and vengeance become so great
that they threaten the existence of the
society the majority of people will
quickly set aside their differences in
order to sacrifice an individual the
scapegoat whose death can restore
temporary peace to the community
everyone agrees that the whole thing was
the scapegoats fault and bam-boom burned
at the metaphorical stake and everyone
chills out but since it's literally
impossible for an immense social
conflict to be entirely one person's
fault the scapegoat is a lie and a
pretty violent one at bat
so peace doesn't last long and
eventually someone covet thy neighbor's
necklace all over again Gerard says that
since humans have an innate impulse
toward violence and rivalry actually
stopping those cycles of vengeance is
basically impossible with one exception
we can replace the scapegoat with a
christ-like figure who rejects violence
and turns the other cheek and this could
set a new imitative trend of people
desiring non-violence Harvey Dent
and his campaign for peace and Gotham
appear to fill that role providing a
Christ figure for the community to
emulate I believe in Harvey that even
Batman who can only fight violence with
violence supports a world where dent
replaces him taking up the mantle of
crime-fighting without the need for
grappling hooks you're the shambhala
phone
I can never be your stand against
organized crime is the first legitimate
ray of light in Gotham in decades but
the Joker a representation of the true
violence of mankind shifts the course of
the mimetic rivalry and corrupts our
Christ figure with a few oil drums and
some sweet talk
once Harvey two-face begins to imitate
the Joker embracing chaos and going
after Gordon and the corrupt cops
he becomes subject to the cycles of
violence that the white knight was
supposed to destroy so in order to
restore peace to Gotham we turn to the
time-honored tradition of the scapegoat
Gotham picks an individual not blames
him for the current social ills in this
case the crimes committed by two-face
and the Joker's presence and punishes
him in order to end the intense
rivalries that threatened the existence
of the community they don't kill Bruce
Wayne but they effectively killed the
symbol of the Batman at least for a
while and during the period where Batman
is gone there is a time of relative
peace and prosperity in the city but the
scapegoat is always based in a lie the
truth of the situation has to be
unconsciously suppressed in order to
achieve the desired effect or containing
the violent impulses of humanity
however this lie is unsustainable and
this problem is the starting point of
the Dark Knight Rises
the third film begins at a time of
relative tranquility brought on and
sustained by the lie of Harvey Dent's
martyrdom and the scapegoating of Batman
this is acknowledged by Courtney the
Batman wasn't needed anymore
who just by recognizing the nature of
the lie threatens the stability that
depends on the mayor's gonna dump him in
the spring really but he's a hero a war
hero
this is peacetime but while the dent Act
made possible by the demonization of
Batman has effectively ended organized
crime there are other kinds of violence
still at work in the city the social and
economic inequalities which define the
third film as one form of violence ends
another begins although it's hardly fair
to say that social inequality is a new
phenomenon in Gotham the Wayne's were
killed because of their wealth but the
dissolution of the mob means that the
divides between the legitimate rich and
the poor are once again in the spotlight
and violent rivalry is inevitable storm
coming mister
you and your friends better batten down
the hatches cuz when it hits
you're all gonna wonder how you ever
thought you could end up so large and
leave the rest like the Joker Bane is
focused on revealing the violence that
already exists in ordinary people but
while the Joker explores the idea of
chaos Bane is interested in the concept
of the law
there were bid supplied with a false
idol to stop you tearing down this
corrupt tear which undoes the peace that
depended on that lie the disruption of
the myth of the scapegoat means that the
sacrifice of Batman no longer serves its
purpose and his disappearance no longer
helps the city
because Batman sacrificed himself in
order to save the city from itself his
return isn't as simple as hopping into a
flying car and catching the bad guy to
inspire the city he has to
metaphorically come back from the dead
which is shown in his ascent out of the
pit there's probably a lot of birth
symbolism happening as he climbs out of
a hole into the sunlight
but what's way more interesting is this
explicit connection to rising from the
dead and the comics the underground cave
has another name the Lazarus Pit if
you're not up to date with your New
Testament stories Lazarus is a dude who
died and Jesus brought him back to life
yeah it's pretty much that simple he
rose from the dead coincidence probably
not especially since later on Gordon
reads a eulogy from A Tale of Two Cities
which describes you guessed it be
christ-like sacrifice of one of the main
characters nolan man you're killing it
with these litters and this leads us
back to Gerard's Christ figure
he claims that in order to have real
lasting peace to remove our society and
ourselves from the cycle of violence we
need to set aside the myth of the
scapegoat and embrace a figure who sets
an example of selflessness that forms a
new mimetic desire to be copied by the
masses but even Gerard isn't sure that
this is feasible if humans are driven by
an innate desire for violence is it
realistic to hope for something
different
Gerard says that even in today's
Christian communities people don't
really follow Christ's example no one
asks this question throughout the
trilogy is peace actually possible
people battle their inner monsters and
at the same time they're battling the
monsters of Gotham but can either of
these ever find true resolution it may
appear that dent was a fake Christ
figure at the end of the dark night
while Batman becomes a legitimate Christ
figure at the end of The Dark Knight
Rises but is this really the case when
Batman takes the bomb out over the ocean
he saves the city from a very visible
kind of violence the radioactive kind
but the peace that follows is also based
in part on the lie that Batman
sacrificed his life to save the city he
gets a statue and the city gets a new
martyr but maybe the lie of Batman's
death is outweighed by another
that unlike dent he really did fight
violence with self-sacrifice creating
the potential for a new kind of memetic
desire
anyone can copy his motivations even if
atomic bombs are in short supply the
idea was to be a symbol that man
that was the point and we see mimesis
come full-circle in Joseph
gordon-levitt's character who was
revealed at the end of the film to be
none other than Robin the fact that
Robin is introduced and that Batman left
him all of his crime-fighting tools
suggests but doesn't prove that piece
may not last in Gotham so how do we
maintain stability in our communities
the openness of the ending person Italy
Robin in the Batcave and Batman all
statute up could lead us in a number of
directions which is exactly Nolan's
point is a scapegoat myth or a lie
necessary to maintain stability can a
Christ figure really inspire people to
abandon their violent urges or can
society never exist without conflict no
matter what we do is there always a
future crisis on the horizon ultimately
to the limits of human nature prevent us
from achieving lasting peace or does the
human spirit allow us to overcome
whatever obstacles may arise
Nolan's later films like interstellar
and Dunkirk give us a peek into the
possibility of how and why we might
transcend those limits by constructing
new worlds tune in next time and thanks
for watching peace
thanks for watching wisecrack we just
want to take a second to thank you for
all the support we love making videos
for you guys but we really couldn't do
it without you
so another way you can support us is by
becoming a patron you'll get immediate
access to exclusive patron only releases
including podcasts a new video on the
movie it's and more than a week before
it hits the channel in October early
access to our upcoming video on mr.
robot and we're working on more patron
exclusives each month including
behind-the-scenes experiments with new
formats like movie reviews quick takes
and more so be sure to check out our
patreon page here or at the link in the
description and if you like this video
and are looking for more nolan check out
our wisecrack edition on the philosophy
of christopher nolan part one by
clicking here thanks a lot you guys
peace
[Music]